and now to a rare
inside look into the secretive royal
family of saudi arabia
overseen by a new crown prince who
manages great wealth and people who have
committed murder rhonda
he's the 35 year old crown prince of the
kingdom of saudi arabia
muhammad bin salman more commonly known
by his initials mbs
brian we're joined now by justin check
and bradley hope
the authors of a great new book blood
and oil
mohammed bin salman's ruthless pursuit
of global power
thank you both for being here uh mbs as
he's known started off we thought as a
great reformer but
justin that's not the case well you know
i i think it's more complicated than
that i think he's someone who's intent
on
maintaining his power and his family's
power in saudi arabia
and what he believes that requires is
having social reforms to make the
country's young population of 60
of the populations below 30 reforms to
satisfy them but also
clamping down on dissent making sure any
threats to the royal family are
addressed and that includes
um external threats like iran like qatar
where he's
been very aggressive the most prominent
target
dissident and washington post columnist
jamal khashoggi
saudi arabia confirms that the
journalist jamal khashoggi is dead
jamal khashoggi entered the saudi
consulate in istanbul
and never came out after his death a
number of mbs associates were convicted
but not the prince himself
well it's not hard for him to do that
because he is ultimately
you know him and his father are the
center of power so
he's taken the position that he he said
publicly it's my fault
that this happened but i didn't order
the murder he told them take care of
this guy
and they took it upon themselves to take
care of them as they saw fit
and it looks like you know from the sort
of the way things played out it looks
like they probably were
trying to kidnap them when they realized
that
would be inconvenient they you know
murdered and dismembered him
so they seemed to be uh acting
on what they thought were his wishes
whether he explicitly said it or not
doesn't really matter that much because
they were
carrying out something on his behalf
uh you and bradley have fascinating
insights inside the
views of what's going on behind the
scenes there including his uh
acquisition of wealth and
status symbols yachts arts tell me a bit
about that
well obviously um this is one of the
reasons why he had to fight so hard
against all these rivals
because when you become the king of
saudi arabia you are immediately
you you have an overwhelming wealth you
know so you just suddenly you get the
biggest
percentage of the royal families
allocation of the oil profits and you
get access to all kinds of other money
as well
so very early on after all all this
wealth suddenly came into
both his father and his own control he
went on a kind of a spending spree
he um he had this crazy party in the
maldives
it was meant to last a month and he
rented it rented out this hotel for 50
million dollars
brought all these people over 150 models
which we would describe in the book
um and then he also bought this high-end
yacht the serene
you know famously his he he and his team
were flying over
i believe in the south of france and
they saw the pla they saw this boat and
they
decided to go take it for a spin and
then not that long after they bought it
sort of the asking price you know they
weren't there was no negotiation really
um and then there's also this immense
chateau in france
um that looks like it belongs to you
know
from the 17th centuries and he's also
justin uh sought some of the world's
most uh
priceless paintings he's 400 million is
the bid
and the piece is sold
[Applause]
famously uh he was a the mysterious
buyer
of a of a division
what's most likely a da vinci painting
it was a the first you know
new da vinci painting to be discovered
or unearthed in
you know many many years and it has its
own strange backstory but you know it
sold for this astonishing amount and
there was all the speculation about who
the mystery buyer was and it turned out
to be
a sort of front buyer for him
given what he wants in terms of global
power what has been his relationship
with the
trump administration well um
really his cultivation of the trump
administration
was both the the key to his own rise in
power
and it's it's the key to his ability to
stay in power over these
periods of years and and and sort of
fend off all of these stats to himself
you know
so by the when by the time the donald
trump was first
elected um mbs still had some issues
about consolidating power and he
what he did was he used that he he
persuaded along with his team
the administration that it would be
worth their while to come to saudi
arabia for their first foreign trip
what what mbs wanted to do was to kind
of go
all out to impress trump and make trump
feel
not just welcomed but honored and
treated as
uh you know a great statesman and an
international leader
and finally let me ask you how important
is it to mbs that donald trump
be re-elected i think it's tremendously
important
um you know he's really
staked a lot of a lot of his power on on
the relationship with america
the uae just recognized israel if saudi
arabia recognizes israel
before the election that that could be a
foreign policy win for trump
so i think there's a lot riding there
because if the democrats come in you
know when biden was vice president
um biden's foreign policy people and
obama's were
very skeptical of saudi arabia overall
and they expressed skepticism about the
war in yemen even though they assisted
with it in the early days
and there was oh you know obama was uh
constantly reminding them of human
rights issues um king saman felt that
hillary clinton was lecturing him on
human rights issues
and so mbs especially really mistrusts
the democrats and
mistrusts their impulse to strike a deal
with iran
and you know it would be a real shift
and it could
you know cause saudi arabia to turn more
toward china or more toward you know
even even russia if biden wins
bradley hope and justin scheck thank you
so much for being here authors of this
great new book
blood and oil muhammad did salman's
ruthless quest for global power
thank you both for being here tonight
thank you thank you